years in the planning old animosities
and rivalries overcome U.S President Joe
Biden believes this is a significant
diplomatic moment this is the first
summit I've hosted at Camp David as
president
I can think of no more fitting location
to begin the next Air our next year of
cooperation a place that has long
symbolized the power of new beginnings
the location was deliberate Camp David
in Maryland a presidential Retreat is
where peace deals have been made
agreements reached breakthroughs
accomplished Japan and South Korea have
a long history of Suspicion and
bitterness but the perceived growing
Menace of China and the Pacific and the
unpredictability of North Korea brought
all three countries together in what Joe
Biden declared was a moment of political
courage regarding the response to North
Korea the three countries agreed to
strengthen cooperation for the full
implementation of sanctions and to work
closely together in the U.N security
Council the Diplomatic ties will be
stronger with a leader level hotline
there will be annual military exercises
and efforts to protect and boost Supply
chains and the economy we have agreed to
step up our security cooperation to
ensure our people's Safety and Security
in the region
but the Americans are Keen to point out
this is not anti-beijing or
anti-pyongyang it's just someone who's
not about China that was not the purpose
of the meeting but it did come China
obviously came up not to say we don't
share concerns about the economic
coercion or heightened tensions caused
by China but this Summit was really
about our relationship with each other
and deepening cooperation across entire
range of issues that went well beyond
the White House says has been working on
this agreement since almost Joe Biden's
first day in office the compact they
insist is designed to last for years and
years but for the moment it's only
second to last as long as Joe Biden
remains in office Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
at Camp David in Maryland